Okay.
Well,
today we're just winding down.
Um,
first of all,
a few concluding reflections to wrap up the course.
Well,
we've now trace the development of a society of a political culture.
Uh,
and indeed in many ways,
uh,
a whole national culture over more than 200 years,
200,
250 years.
Um,
I promise when we started off in lecture one that would be looking at some great
personalities,
some great events,
and some great processes.
And I hope that that promise has been met.
Uh,
we've had the great personalities,
warts and all with or without heads.
We've also traced a changing political culture,
the development of the institutions of representative government,
the eventual taming of personal monarchy,
the development of concepts of the rule of law,
of political participation,
of notions of liberty under the law.
We've also looked at the emergence,
the early stages of the emergence of a fully capitalist market economy,
and indeed its connections to a nascent world economy.
And we've looked at the transition from a late medieval society of orders to
watch can reasonably be described as a nascent class society.
We've looked at a transformation in religious culture,
the eventual acceptance of attentative,
pluralism,
toleration in matters of belief and of course we've looked at enormous changes
in levels of education in popular literacy and the print culture that served
these and so on and throughout all of this in many ways we've looked at the
hammering out of the conflicts to which all of these processes gave rise and
eventually the finding of ways to deal with those conflicts peaceably.
Well these are things of some significance they up most obviously to the extent
that some of the events and processes that we've been examining this period have
left a legacy in the modern world in terms of institutions,
in terms of values,
in terms of ideas and that's not just true of England or Britain,
but also have a larger world that at one time or another was subject to petition
fluence it firsthand or secondhand to that extent.
Many of these things are widely shared legacy and worth knowing something about
they are in the words of one tutor chronicler in his definition of history,
their tales useful to be known.
Okay.
And all that is one form of what Peter last lit in his famous phrase described
as understanding ourselves in time,
but when he used that phrase,
he also meant something larger.
You meant reflecting on the actual nature of the historical process.
Now,
of course one can do that for any period of history for any country.
They're all equally valuable as human experience though the stories and the
meanings very,
we've looked at one particular case,
but it also serves to illustrate some general points about the historical
process and I'll raise them briefly.
First of all,
of course,
history is process.
We're looking at societies which are in constant motion.
Change is the heart of the matter.
People change societies and their institutions change,
their values,
change,
their identities change.
An outline course of this kind of helps to reveal that and early modern England
certainly illustrates that general truth.
It was a time,
obviously enough of the breaking of worlds and of the making of worlds of the
erosion of old certainties and identities and structures and the creation of new
ones.
Secondly,
historical change of this kind is messy.
It's complex and messy and in many ways ambiguous
history is never scripted in advance.
Historians who have an ideological cast of mind might like to pretend that it is
and to describe historical processes out as though they have a certain
inevitability leading to preconceived ends of one kind or another,
but they deceive themselves.
Nothing in history is preordained.
Some change may be the successful outcome of deliberately planned action,
but a great deal is the result of improvised responses to immediate
contingencies and in both cases there are always the unforeseen consequences.
The history of early modern England illustrates this well enough.
Think of the Henry Finn Reformation or think of the regicide and what followed
it or think of the long working out of the outcome of the revolution of 60 and
so it's not scripted in advance and it's not synchronized either.
Change of different kinds of proceeds at different paces.
We've looked at political change,
economic change,
social change,
cultural change.
We've seen the urgency with which political change can often take place,
but then there are also those processes which are of a very gradual,
very slow and cumulative nature worked out over generations and uneven in their
long term impact.
Think of the uneven spread of literacy,
for example,
the processes of economic change that I've looked at as a result at any one
point in time,
any society is a kind of mixture of forms because change is uneven because it's
partial,
so the process is messy,
but nonetheless in all of this,
one can find patterns.
One can trace connections.
If it wasn't so one would not be able to offer interpretations of the process of
change.
One wouldn't be able to offer arguments about the nature of causation.
And again,
looking at a particular society over a long period of time helps one to
appreciate this aspect of the study of history.
It reveals the interconnections.
It reveals the way things work their way through over time,
but no single interpretation ever encompasses it all.
Of course,
no single interpretation ever holds all the answers.
How can one simply answer a question like,
when did England become Protestant and what did that mean?
Anyway,
that's why of course we constantly need to revise our views of it all.
In the light of new evidence,
in the light of new imaginative insights on the part of historians,
we can never hold a recover the past.
It's gone.
It's drowned in time,
but we can enter a dialogue with the evidence that it has left and by doing that
remake the past again and again in the present according to our changing
preoccupations and are changing understandings,
finding new dimensions of what was going on previously,
neglected finding new meanings.
You want understandings,
and this is very evident in the ongoing debates over all the major issues of
this particular period and the way that new issues are constantly emerging.
Well,
it's because of that complexity that I've tried to present an account of change
in this period that is complex and many faceted that includes many dimensions,
the political,
the economic,
the social,
the cultural,
each of them making its own contribution to an overall process.
Each of them helping to make the overall process comprehensible
and it's because of the ambiguities in all of this that I've tried to adopt a
variety of perspectives,
looking at things from the Catholic point of view and from the Protestant point
of view,
from an arc,
the monarchical from the populist history as viewed from the top or from the
bottom or from the middle history wearing Rich's history dressed in a gown,
and there's a point to all of this.
The point is simply that history contains many stories,
all of which deserve to be told.
It contains in the evidence that leaves to us many voices,
all of which deserve to be heard.
No one owns the past.
It's common land.
There's no velvet rope denying access.
It's not a gated community.
The Dad in the evidence,
they lead to us.
We'll talk to anyone.
They're very nice that way.
I've also tried repeatedly to give a sense of the context within which people
lived,
made their decisions and choices and acted.
And again,
there's a very simple historical philosophy behind that,
which is sneakily stated in the old adage that people make their own history,
but they don't make it just as they choose.
They make it within contexts and under conditions that are not of their own
choosing,
some of which are inherited,
some of which are newly encountered,
some of which can be anticipated,
some of which take them by surprise,
but by their actions and responses and choices,
they can change their world.
They're always within certain constraints and to understand that process and the
outcomes,
we need to understand the context within which people acted in their own time,
in their own ways,
according to their own lights.
One of the most important of such context is of course the structures of power
in any society
in determining action,
in initiating change.
Some people carried more weight,
some had more clout.
We've seen examples,
enough of that in early modern England,
in the political sphere,
in the economic sphere and elsewhere,
but we've seen examples too of the fact that power can be resisted.
It can be confronted,
it can even be put under restraint.
People make their own history,
they can alter the contexts sometimes quite significantly reshaping the world
that is encountered by the next generation.
And that in a sense has been the core of the narrative element of this course.
So to conclude,
things change.
Change is messy,
it's ambiguous and it's meaning.
There are many interconnected stories.
History has many voices.
People make their own history,
but not just as they please.
And if some have more power than others to call the shots.
They don't have to have it all their own way,
nor did they
reflecting on the process as a whole gives a history of any period and any
country it's meaning.
It's many meanings and that's why it's worth bothering.
In studying history,
we constantly reconstruct the past in the present,
disciplined as we do it by respect for the evidence which it leaves to us,
but drawn in to examine and to reexamine that evidence by the problems which we
ourselves feel the need to understand.
Each of us has drawn almost instinctively to those aspects of the past which
continue to resonate to us individually,
across the centuries because they speak to us for reasons we sometimes might not
fully understand.
They speak to our preoccupations,
they speak to our dilemmas and you're trying to understand them.
We can not only understand ourselves better in time,
but also see possibilities for the future.
Historical events can often be dismaying,
but historical study is ultimately encouraging.
It's concerned with change,
with possibility,
with adaptation,
with finding ways.
It's concerned with human experience and achievement of every kind.
Sustaining a sense of that ancestry
is important in what sometimes seems and increasingly frivolous and d
historicized western culture with an extremely shallow awareness of its own past
that can result in a kind of disorientation.
History in contrast,
tries to understand,
do you understand what we have been to raise questions and suggestions and
implications for what we might be capable of becoming,
and that's why history,
all history matters.
It really does matter.
Okay,
well that's my little sermon and now we're going to have a short award ceremony.
Okay.
For which I must prepare myself.
Right.
I hereby Declare Myself Supreme Head of the history department.
Yeah.
Hence forward.
Oh,
knew my interpretations will be taught and hence forward or books published by
members of the department will contain a groveling dedication to me.
Um,
but uh,
even,
uh,
the most horrid tyrant cannot rule alone.
You need an aristocracy
and aristocracies as you know,
need to be rewarded.
And so we have an award ceremony to reward our teaching fellows,
the russet coated captains of this course who,
uh,
who know what they teach and love what they know.
Okay.
Now I have some nominations for these awards here prepared for me by Thomas
Cromwell
right now.
Festival.
What do we have here?
Yes.
Okay.
We have the,
uh,
the Henry the eighth award for devotion to family values.
Okay.
And for being a top redhead,
go ahead and survive.
Okay.
And now we have the Elizabeth,
the first award for not making windows into students souls and for keeping
advisers in that place.
And looking ahead to the stewards succession,
which I've done my best to avoid,
but unfortunately it's going to happen.
So my suits to say is,
tell me we have the,
uh,
the King Charles,
the second award,
the last real king,
the King Charles,
the second award for being tall,
dark,
and partly French,
and for staying cool and carrying on Justin.
Bye.
Okay,
so that's it.
Do remember to let me know if you intend to come to the center for British art
tomorrow morning for the last visit there.
Uh,
and,
uh,
now we'll turn to a housekeeping matters and they'll tell me a little bit about
the nature of the exam.